All results.
Reasons don't count.
Parks will always point out reasons on
why they are not living their dream on
why they are not manifesting their
greatness.
They will always be able to point those
things out,
but none of those things count.
The only thing that counts or results
and results don't lie.
Ladies and gentlemen,
they tell it all judge a tree by the
fruit that it bears,
not the ones that it might talk about,
not the ones that it might wish for,
but the fruit that it actually bears.
The people that are committed are busy
doing it,
but I think that some of us are
producing results in our lives that that
level of commitment brains that we
particularly don't like or find is
tasteful.
You want to take care of yourself.
I don't think that as a participant in
life,
you cannot be committed.
You either committed to mediocrity or
you're committed to greatness.
You're either committed to being
productive or you're committed to being
nonproductive.
You committed to being happy,
or you're committed to being unhappy.
Once I look at how you commit your time
one time doing an evaluation on how you
spend your time.
I can tell you exactly what you're
committed to.
People that say they have dreams or one
open a business or want to do something
differently than what they're now doing.
They don't like their jobs.
They're unhappy,
they're unfulfilled.
People said they want to improve their
income level.
Look at how they spend their time.
Commitment shows up in your life and
what you do.
Yeah,
you can make the commitment to your
life,
but you don't like the results that you
have and that you're going to do
something about it.
See,
that power is available to all of us.
People who look at life and decide,
I want something different for myself.
So most people like them using the
language,
they don't want to commit themselves
because commitment means among many
things.
No,
it's stills is acceptable.
You decided that you want to Jill this
if it becomes pop and then do it if it
difficult,
if it's inconvenient.
So what?
What would your life be like if you
decided to keep your commitments?
What we'll all have our lives be like if
we decided to keep our commitments that
we decided to do the things that we said
that we were going to do,
but we wouldn't even speak it unless we
were going to do it
right.
I will do anything unless I'm going to
do it.
At the end of the seven days,
you'll feel strong and powerful.
There's nothing as powerful as the human
spiritual,
Qantas,
it.
When you are committed,
you're dancing to the beat of a
different drummer.
Don't expect people to understand.
Don't expect it to make sense to
anybody.
Why you got to do this?
Why do you have got to go?
Why did you leave this as a good job?
They take you away
from retirement.
I'm going,
why?
I don't understand.
You don't have to
look to this day for it is life.
The very life of light in its brief
costs lie,
all the realities and their of
existence,
the bliss of growth,
the splendor of action,
the glory of power for yesterday is but
a dream.
And tomorrow is only a vision.
But today,
the day well lived makes every yesterday
a dream of happiness.
And every tomorrow a vision of hope.
Look well.
Therefore to this day.